welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sake and today we have a very special
guest swami Ananda hello hello thank you
for jesting with us they did my good
pleasure an honor to be here thank you
for inviting me Ellen I really
appreciate it thank you
swami is one of the leaders in
spirituality and he has been in this
space for a long time since 1991 1991
so become Swami in 1967 became Swami in
67 and Swami means a spiritual master
the spiritual guide yes and it's more
and more Western civilization is being
guided towards the meeting realizing
spirituality is it important
exactly - no no there's too much
awareness in the world about the woman
using their human development yes so I
lead a very balanced happy and
prosperous life and this is changing and
challenging world so now they are
realizing the importance of a spiritual
science yes spiritual science yes in
particular what I call it meditations
yes so I said this is a spiritual
sciences science of inner management
inner management management yes so I
call it the 21st century cutting-edge
innovation AHA inner management yes
exactly
and I read sadguru's book inner
engineering yeah that guy yeah my you
know management I love it yeah and it is
exactly that that it's not much them
yeah trimming inward why why has the
east why have they been so much more
deeply rooted in inner management than
the West because it's about the cultural
thing you know it's about the philosophy
of life and so for a spirituality is
concerned it is in DNA of entire human
being so I had this practical tools in
the moment it's very old as long as
their civilization was there at the
human being came into existence
but the beauty of an area this
meditation because the Indian lifestyle
is a part and parcel of the Indian
lifestyle so that's why it is coming up
so now it's general awareness in the
West also because due to the science and
technological development because in the
very beginning that spirituality we
consider as a religion as an organized
institution like you know Catholicism
you know or other religions you know so
now the people have move ahead because
it to do the change of Science and
Technology the world has as we say can
we live in a global village we live in
interconnected in the dependent world
like India we seem to oh where is India
in the global map you know today we can
see in the globe here is India the
people are travelling so therefore
recycle this whole world as a Indian
philosophy says but soothe a worker to
become Vasudeva Tomica who to come the
whole world is one family oh yes because
we live in interconnected and
independent world so for all these
things like so today the life in spite
of all material advancement and
technological advancement because after
what what is the technology technology
is it tools it means to connect outside
world so what is the technology who can
connect to your inner self because today
what you find today the people we live
in a digital era
so I say there is more meeting less
meaning oh that's good didn't it were
meetings less many many more cuting less
truth more tweeting less truth more
texting less talk more texting was
talking isn't it so what happened but so
this taken logic cannot so what I just
said just now key technology is immense
is it not the key suppose through the
technology we connected yes support
through the email with right lot of mail
L on computers
but the physical that is different
suppose we write the same letter under
time oh honey I love you I love you I
love you I care about you but when you
meet a person and just embrace or have a
hug a little a different thing yeah so
technologic cannot be substitute for the
home and development and humans desire
and fulfillment of desire or for educate
evenness to know more so all the
advancement of material world there is
inside empty so that's why they are
looking toward the other way of life
like today the world health is
completely broken so they're finding
some other way to address those physical
well-being
so therefore the comprehends if there is
a holistic approach I don't call it
balance but I call it holistic your
present yes harmonious living yes so I
give you example like a garden if you go
to Golden Gate Park there to garden one
is called Rose Garden and one is it
called botanical garden so why we call
Rose Garden we called a rose garden
because it's Aeschylus array of rows in
but you go to Botanical Garden there are
different kinds of flowers like there is
a tuberose marigold and all that so what
did live they live side by side they
don't feel themselves as a threatened
yes so they live in harmony so at the
same time a human being we had the
different skills
suppose I'm analytical engineer you are
have a different skill you know like a
electronics and other thing other people
they have there are some doctors there
somewhere that attorney so what do that
different like a human body's human is
in a singular body composed of many
things like the right hand left hand
right eye left eyes you know lungs heart
kidneys you see how they're so so they
all do work in synchronicities so the
how to live harmonious life so that you
can be a person can be happy have a
peace and tranquility
because this all the advancement
technology like any web
you're not going to solve those
procedural problems though the emotional
problems suppose it requires inner
management yeah so that's why I say key
how to so therefore there is the general
awakening and now as I we see that
everywhere so as a hole in the world
like a especially in America or in take
word they have been embraced meditation
in their lifestyle and so is it military
embrace technology because it so as I
was talking case what is a spirituality
a spiritually transcendent is not
certain belief in certain dogma
it is a utilization yeah the truth rely
so when you realize the truth that's
basically we are on human being
irrespective of how we dress how we
looked
what is the social status how much
education power whether becomes a
material so that is how to grow like you
want to manage life we want to manage
business you want Amanda's family so
what is the so suppose example yeah
you're in the morning we go go to the
kitchen and we say you're thinking what
should i do should I make a sandwich so
America is the country of of so many
choices so then I start how the mind
react when you come outside word you say
which bridge should I make it whole
bread or this bread or that bread then
say I have to make a sandwich then say
what kinds of cheese I should use
cottage cheese American cheese you see
how it goes there's a so they make a no
onions no onions because no pickles
correct so I did you get confused so
when I get confused you make it total
mess because you are in this is him
versus when somebody gives you weeds in
which a tomato lettuce and you only get
one option what I'm saying because this
is the your life so you are not
functioning well we're confused so what
is called this is called outside word
because those come in contact of outside
so when your mind is a calm and cool and
relaxed instead of say let me take cold
bread make a switch quarters yes that's
it
yup when you go to traders oh I say what
kind of ice cream should I have so we
are confusing at the wedding you know I
should I have bunny lassoed I have this
so then II where this is not take me
have vanilla what is the big deal so we
have outside world and they can't ask
you then the inside world outside world
has so many variables and choices and
confusion that what I'm saying but it
also is making lots of good progress
absolutely within all these good ways
but it is so much noise and when I was
very little signal right now and -
especially what the East has built it
into culture to tune in yeah so that way
we can better find the signal in
ourselves in the outside world
otherwise then outside world controls us
so that what's the difference the peace
and tranquility it's likely the people
there they're burnt out at the job that
is stressed out you know so so when you
are there when your mind is a common
cold
you don't react so that what is the
cause with deservings our trunk later
peace of mind because the external
bombardment suppose you get caught in
the traffic's huge external bomb no
suppose it going like we are living on
the market estate when you walk on them
artistic they lot of noise so what the
demand it disturb you at wrong qulity
you react it you get too mad you know so
but when you are calm and cool say
that's okay let somebody honking why
should I piss my wife yeah so that what
a second you wish them together peace so
how to manage the inner side that
technique that is called meditation the
science of spirituality yeah so that's
why I say key meditation is a natural it
is simple and easy there is no ritual so
there are four sacred meditation might
taking I have to call it meditation for
the modern life because everybody say I
don't have time yeah isn't it so I said
you know just ten or fifty
in a corporate and you can change your
life
huge change the word semi-good if -
suppose it is simple things when you are
happy you are more creative more
operative more efficient yes so when all
the offi absolutely because that affects
it like the fiscal health because
they're intertwined yes
the physical and the mental wavering yes
see they're all intertwined some point
in the body so therefore once we have
therefore why we are consciously about
today when you go to grocery we read all
the levels what are the contents of
carbohydrate fat DS and there so we want
to eat healthy because think I have to
be healthy so I have to eat right food I
have to exercise so these are physical
things because the fits so interesting
because them when you when somebody
tells somebody else like the dogma of
belief I may say if you think this way
not then you will have less suffering
you will be more in control more happy
more creative more healthy people say I
don't want to be taught how to think but
when you maybe put it in terms of
nutrition yeah and then you say okay
well you know you want to eat healthy
yeah don't you want to think healthy as
well there's so many of these analogies
for life then if we can just make it
more relatable for people but
non-dogmatic
I think we should talk about that a
little bit because what is the
meditation practices if it's if it's
anything works for meditation what is
most effective though and it is it is it
actually different for all seven and a
half billion people know it's a for
everybody therefore you say according to
our Indian philosophy we say get the
very purpose of our human existence
through realize your true self who you
are yeah because well not only the food
system and the kolos and shelter this is
not we are not 100% physical beings we
have the emotional being like the
feeling of love and affections and all
those things so this is called mental
thing emotional things
so how to add the snow the emotional
thing like as I said he like suppose you
slice a part of the body the blood will
spill on the table but slice a part of
the brain the there is no artistry we
can collect the feeling of emotions and
love or anger
so this is called a mental this emotion
since much higher than the physical
level and then there's something where
it comes from there so there I gave an a
lotta that man is just like a ocean and
mine has got three character that is a
constantly wandering wavering and
rippling wandering wavering wavering and
rippling rippling unexplained yeah so
support I'd say in the common word you
can say what is the mind mind is just
like a monkey and one can means that
it's it ideal for a few seconds our life
because my you were here we are thinking
something so too much the circle outside
bombardment there's a constant war is
going on so meditation is the process
which declares a no war zone so there's
no custom work is happening all the time
were remain unaffected even just turning
off yeah a vision of course that it so
much less stimulus in yeah so that makes
it easier to do inner management of
course yes because suppose you do senses
upward eyes suppose here we keep the
eyes open we are saying so many things
here this incrementals glow of this a
lumira this is how bad is it yet so they
are all destructed especially on Market
Street here in this room yes so the
moment you close our eyes then what is
happening we are trying to be draw from
outside world
and when you looked inside then suppose
you watch your breath then the breath
you know suppose when a person is angry
breath is very faster and so when the
heart rates faster faster more stress
yeah levels are higher for in just in
case need to fight flight yeah of course
a the signal goes there they know so
that stress
Harmons go up and they call it chorus
tall you know so they're feeling of
fight and flight but when your mind is a
common code and that's why when the
people are very angry say take a step
back take a deep breath so when you are
taking breath means you are trying to
control the other part of the body like
all the senses because now it then goes
to the mind
so when therefore in the introduced
energy certain sound vibration which you
call mantras so you with those because
though the mantra brings syncro cities
with the brain so by repetition of doing
this using certain sound wave because I
said key what is tranquillity trunk leti
means rhythm plus the vibration equal
tranquility
then that means so the rhythm is your
breathing and and tranquility is very
similar to equanimity getting exact so
no sir no no hyper craving lots of
emotions right no it's totally comity
means there is no filling the total
peace there is no thought is set of
thoughtlessness thoughtlessness yes no
disturbance nothing this dest it and
that what you call say the deeper level
of your consciousness you are being
because the outside world is with the
conscious mind in the sleep this called
subconscious maya and beyond that called
causal mind so the meditation process we
start from the physical level means
conscious level and then we transform to
the mental level and from there you
transform where the state of reach a
state that what you call say how to as I
was saying we live in this world a
digital era where you say aqui I don't
have time to even sleep have a good
sleep
or even to think properly or to more
have more creative ideas or efficiently
so all the time people feel tired and
exhausted yeah so you have to discharge
like the cell phone you have to turn it
off and then hugging in
so the spiritual science is to recharge
our own self so that is it give a
certain a tremendous amount of s
strengthen esteem in our inspirations
which helps us to deal or today's life
challenges with equanimity
yes not with the panic because all the
time they will panic better something
happened it will lose everything you
lose the sleep will raise your appetite
for example a person loses a job
then he goes into depression because
feel how can I pay my mortgage how can I
pay my tuition fees and then he can't
eat he can't sleep so how it disturb the
whole thought process and equanimity so
there for a second this more internal
happiness continue are who are more
happier were more peaceful then we are
more creative more freedom so your whole
things will be change because today we
see with the microcast copic view we
started judging how he dressed who is
well my score is very well demand this
and that so then you can find yourself
but as you develop internally you were
thinking changes and you think of the
world with the telescopic view so the
meditation for the what's the love
scopic view that was worn telescope it
means 360 degree angle of thinking the
reason whereas you are thinking with 65
degrees 75 degree or something that was
called say Neuros mindedness
yes so it's all about the power of turin
suppose we simply say or let it go
forgive but we keep hanging and that's
why we are not able to move ahead until
this you cross that things we can't go
ahead so that so this things is all
about the mental growth your inner
growth so more happy one and what I was
saying inner growth means the
development of 360 degree so it come
positive are telling the beginning you
feel like you know the whole world is my
family
I remember of the whole world I have not
I am not only San Franciscan I'm not
only Californian but I've not the United
State but I belongs to the whole world
so it is my thing
what based and form I can bring
happiness and joy to anybody else not
only search in the psychology of only
taking taking taking what you'll say no
giving giving giving so that's why my
aim of life is to love all serve all yes
love all yeah so this is my you know
philosophy of life yes
and so you were touching about this you
said that there's we were talking about
how all these different ways to meditate
you know these non-dogmatic ways and we
have for example you were - we were
talking about breath work closing the
eyes we're talking about breath work and
then we were talking a little bit about
mantra and so there's this I am grateful
for this I am grateful for that and
there's a bunch of different mantra work
that can be done so and what would you
recommend maybe for four people because
everyone's different but breath work ice
closed mantra work what that's an idea
tzedakah now as a second there is a
general awareness about a spirituality
like I was saying that more than 20
American people they practice meditation
they've been corrupted to me medicine to
enhance their quality of life and to
face the challenges with a smile so
they're like mindful meditations
you know guided meditation in 90 the TM
8 is not very popular Transcendental
Meditation so I said get those a kind of
meditation I had like in technology you
see how the technology had chains as we
just like we live in a digital world
like in the beginning we had the floppy
days now we have those things are gone
like we have tabletop to laptop to
tabletop the same thing the when they
were like algorithms or
addicting so now it's like that will you
have iPhone so what is this so this is
so that the technology has exponential
growth in the every field that the
exponential growth in the field of
medicine he said how the very beginning
they were talking about one one school
of thought like at the conventional
medicines now they're incorporating
traditional medicine like you say the
Tai Chi our Vedas homeopathy a natural
path is that combining I don't call it
complementary it's called combined
demented medicine yeah so the growth so
this is so so there you find so they
also at the time demand so that the
technology exchange we have to be at the
time passes you have to go with what in
Americans they go with the flow so also
the time suppose many ways to travel you
to travel by bullet card then you travel
by the horses you're riding horses and
now we have the you go by no Amtrak now
we will have to go jet flight so how the
time is flying by
so therefore the people they have all
the time excuse I don't have time
because what we have enough time to
because how so the science of meditation
I was talking about in science of inner
management suppose the people how many
people we get REM sleep very few so even
we're toasting and turning on the bed
six to eight hours
how much time we waste I had I was
teaching one time and anger management I
was saying that how so how much time we
will spend like 24 hours you lie down
bed or 8 or 10 hours 8 hours work he
said there no committing one hour I had
all the statistics and so little maybe
four hours so this is how two minutes
with the question of so that's why this
what you call say you were skilled how
to manage it yeah so I say keep this
spiritual practice the meditation is
inner management for support
I call it K no medication but meditation
No
no medication no medication but maybe
meditation yeah I said the 45 minute
minute ation equivalent to eight hours
sleep yeah and it is a natural it easy
which never cause any side effects
because if you take any drugs even a ton
and all and anywhere or sleeping pills
or anyone like a painted represent drag
like in a 91 the project we came in
darling for American people everybody or
Don the project project you know now
today how it finding how its project
meditation COP opiate you know yes yes
so I said yeah how it should yeah and
it's so expensive is there for a second
medic the health is it totally broken
because its cost driver so here that
what we call sneaky footing there so I
was telling the very outset came my
approach is a non-judgmental none of the
tools non-sectarian yes it so I call it
a spiritually it is a way of life yes
so incorporate just at least 10 to 15
minutes and can change your whole life
so therefore it's very practical
appliance and it out of box thinking
so I call my view recommend close eyes
and I say cue my medicine technique is
more lettuce technique than those
outdated meditation I call it meditation
iPhone 6 so that can it be iPhone 10 now
I of course at the moment of this at
this hour I second my meditation is more
scientific more rational and therefore I
have term is called science of energy
management so it's not rituals in ought
to just sit just morning and evening so
I incorporate and integrate in the
psychology it is called you know
habitual habits how do we see earth as
this economic and political system that
has very little ethics or morality we
have a finite resources on the planet
and there's lots of money and greed and
power and all these different dynamics
that are going into earth how do you see
us besides doing the meditation practice
my medicine the vital because I said is
all about the psychology of human beings
so what do you today our psychology it's
only I me and myself yeah in it
it's only me me me me me elevator so we
don't so when you feel icky it's not
only I there my very existence depend on
so many things isn't it
suppose you have body if we don't have
fresh here you get suffocated you get
asthma how can I live the life I suppose
eyes if I did the right vision then you
see everything then you could enjoy the
beauty of the nature yes isn't it so you
are dependent so many things environment
water air isn't it
so it is our moral imperative obligation
that we have to be conscious I must take
care of the planet yeah I'm not destroy
the planet not like as I said because
this because this is the selflessness
yes we don't think about other people so
there suppose what is the well suppose
even the money doesn't give happiness
all the world
no power opposition because these are
transitory because a person like say
about Bill Gates or mark mone off there
which people have or like what you call
say what is the brain the emergent guy
and that Amazon or immature phases you
know do you think they're more happiest
person in the world
no we don't think so yeah they have
money but there's nothing you know so
because when they feel and that's why
not all the about the home and develop
when the people think about others so
the care about you know my existence
also depend on so many things
so it's my moral of
negation that I had to be conscious
suppose I should not waste more water
because the people don't have water to
drink yeah like you were protecting our
here so that's I so which separate the
deforestation environment ik plant and
one on all these things
so therefore second you have to think
that the whole world is this Sergei
would leave we have to live in
harmonious yes and if I give about those
flowers if they live side by side but
today we feel ourself threatened suppose
I say Oh Ellen if if I give me my share
my ideas or thing he'll become rage and
he'll be far ahead than me and I'll
become poorer but a second oh I have
different a skill Ellen has different
skill let me see if I ever to help you
some other way let me see it yeah if we
have this idea in our head in specially
if so can rally just share the idea with
other people because sometimes you do
you want to bring the idea to them that
light others that's what I'm saying so
this is called greed you know because
you don't care suppose it'll take them
parasitical company they know that the
project or like opiate the note that the
doctor prescribes us no I love all of
addiction addiction so those are the
things so so when you think you know I
do something very creative to enhance
the human potential and therefore a
second technology is a means and I had a
Steve Jobs said get across it doesn't
solve everything and technology not
everything there different aspect of
life and their first taking meditation
spirituality is the key to unlock your
inner finite human potential yes and
growth had their circumaural more growth
so it's a golden key that golden comes
what yes it is nothing nothing better at
unlocking maximal human attention then
meditation correct exactly because the
knowledge worth of the books and
technology is limited yeah because like
you want to have a critical where it
comes it comes from the mind and impacts
of perspective the rush
breathe that what a secular holder
management yeah helps you with people
skills helps you with the way you eat
the way you see the ecosystems of the
planets all of it yeah because they were
over that therefore I said you don't Eve
you the world with a microscopic but you
view the world with telescopic we don't
we with the angle of sixty degree or 75
degrees a degree but you think with 300
degrees so how to develop that how to it
all growth so they're only through
because of the books if not come because
that's why the people are so greedy and
you know the sole self-centered so this
is very interesting lots of people that
come on to the show typically talk about
technology being a solution yeah and in
a very powerful solution and me too I
speak about things like for example we
know desalination of water right that's
science to figure that out and provide
clean water for people or science to
help with people's health so that we
don't have deaths at age of three or age
of 18 but we can have death long or
happen way later in life so they're very
spiritual it's pure science yeah it's
just pure mathematics okay so it doesn't
conflict for more using your eyes tickle
OD or not any of struggle in the path
but I second who make the technology
suppose our regular time and all the
planning who does it the human brain
yeah isn't it here so I do well for
since whenever mind is calm and cool
then you can create more creative things
the more you know program and all that
and that's why it's coming up so it's
not technology doing it's not the takin
all this solving the problem that the
very outside cell key taken already
cannot be substituted for the home
ending so it's the human being that
rates the technology that solves the
problem of so yes so so again it's it
comes back to the human being having
some sort of moral or ethical
consideration for what their technology
their bring exactly exactly that what
I'm saying it there we'll quickly I'd
like make life easier so that the P
people can achieve can achieve whatever
they want or connected so with not with
the profit motive but the
service-oriented motive so that's what I
said could therefore the whole problem
is service oriented instead of profit
oriented yeah that's a big bidding
because the divided console economies
are so based on GDP and it's based on
being the first one to market and to be
the one that think it's the cheapest
cheaper products for outsourcing labor
and for how can we maximize shareholder
interest all these variables in the
economic system they don't help maximize
value and utility and flourishing but
they actually maximize the profit side
of the what I'm saying therefore to have
the problem to solve all the problem
what's going on in every field of work
in the personal life and the social life
you know so this is because all about
mental growth so there is a key that in
the the psychology of me my myself that
particle say I so I said the letter is
stand for illness to how to transform
this I went to V you are called wellness
W address for wellness so this spiritual
science helps you to develop that no not
me alone but that others also
I'm exist because that other people's
also there is it also good Swami to take
a little bit of collectivity is it good
but how much individuality though
because if I want to realize my own
potential I should have a little bit of
a little bit of ego so I can help bring
it to the world but also be very aware
of the US and the wheel yes I am there
for example e we are sitting here so you
are here so this is here and Ronnie it's
all collectively we are doing it yes
suppose if it's arrest will not do this
and you are not with doing that how can
we do that yes so we should feel you
know we are all together into it so
there is make easier and we are more
happy so when you do the things
and we realize it for example once the
time I was going from here to Los
Angeles so I was taking the flights and
there were the announcement the flight
would be late due to some mechanical
difficult problem ok 90% of the fly it's
like no no
so then I was sitting at the window then
I sigh and the ground level that people
are working so I started thinking ok
then I said oh you see in the plane that
is one flight flight oh yeah correct
pilot pilot yes so pilot cannot fly
there I serve iron it's engineer
technician because this guy would not
solve the problem the technical glitch
yes isn't it so here solving engineer
yes so in DNA also carrying some other
person also ground people you know so
you see the here is a pilot held
engineer so some things oh it's totality
the I haven't I have a very funny phrase
that I used to say a lot and then it I
kind of got buried in my notes and I
didn't bring it into life but I said see
a bird make a plane yeah thrown away
like a coffee cup exactly so for so for
me that means you back in a hundred
years ago you see the bird that how can
we make inspiration humans can fly
thousands of people work on the you know
the Boeing planes that transit people
examined when we sit in the plane we
treat the whole thousands of people and
all the inspiration just like a plastic
coffee cup that we sewed everyone I
meant a second individual is there
because who contribute individual
society we live in the world what to
leave the world I have been peaceful
everyone has to contribute support today
we say that conflict in the as I say in
the present life suppose how we can
don't have friendship friends who happen
when the two people have this some sort
of similarity then the friends will come
suppose why you have so it's inevitable
individual count but I said psychology
has to be change
whatever you achieve you must be
thankful to other people also yeah
so when you take that one then it you
feel happy but when think you know like
so for example if I go I'm the boss I
can
so my the ego you are saying mistreat J
or Ron but you know there are part of my
team
yes I have to respect so much respect no
because they say I cannot do myself I
have a smile around here so there for a
sec this feelings discounts yeah what
what is your thought about where the
consciousness comes from because we have
evolution produced the atoms and the
cells and the body but then where did
the consciousness come from yeah the
consciousness come because it that was
recommended as you feel okay how like
when the mother conceived a child so
before that there is no milk in her
breast but ad she conceives gradually
gradually the changes and you can see
the biological change in the mother's
womb and and her behavior and all that
it changes so that the conception it
takes and then when she delivered that
the moment they can say there is
consciousness there for example we have
the same consciousness that I have but
they have the less development suppose
we what exact momento when the sperm yes
for the conception a moment yeah yeah at
that moment or are we talking about when
it's already the started to form in
quantity so is it once the brain shows
up it comes when the woman conceived and
grows gradually gradually so
consciousness slowly increase it's there
but it's expressed for example but where
does it come from how does it start
there's a it doesn't just come from the
brain being formed does it come from
some place outside of
or if they're standing or how you know
this is the question of you know how the
creation is started you know so it it is
like we know suppose it's very beginning
because it likes example when men or men
meet and then you know not the signs
have proved that the how the chromazone
and or DNA know all kind of things you
know it comes up so that's how they
contribute you know like main chromatin
and by deciding the gender killed the
mimic chromatin more powerful then it
will be boy if the ladies Chrome OS is
more there than there will be good so
that decided so it comes through the
nature you know when the nature have
convinced for example different kinds of
flowers so the nature is always good so
how we created you can craft it you know
like suppose I wanted to have less said
and what fruits then you craft it like
Apple you crafted plant so something
human we gets women and well we gets
women so this is the mystery which
cannot be solved and that's how it
called desire to know that their circuit
Who am I
so then to realize that this you cannot
win known through the books but you have
to look to within and then you realize K
I am the same infinitum brahmasmi so I'm
the same divine and I'm one one and this
is my journey to become from drop to
become part of the ocean and that's what
life is a journey to be coming from
incomplete to complete and that is our
progress and that's I say K there
suppose you throw water on the floor it
goes down means it has to go and merge
into the ocean and there it has got what
you call say Nirvana or salvation so in
our life also there the constant
struggle journey till you reach to the
goal and realize the truth
I'm divine yeah and that is the
technique to know that one to look
within and to look within the tool is
science of spirituality called
meditation yes in the other world what -
Siri I call it 21st century cutting-edge
innovation science of inner management
yes so if you more happy more creative
are there more productive are there so
whole psychology will be changed from I
to we from the incomplete to the
complete
how can a parent become a better guide
for their children at a young age to go
towards completeness yeah because the
very beginning for example you know like
it's also likely say I was there he's a
novice turn he's in North Carolina as
well so I had visited him he had just
five six years of oil
his name was America to Indian girl she
has a name Indian name
Arun so I went for walk so then on the
stair there are some mystique say it
took that a stick and he striking on the
students say it's not an ax stupid area
is not an ax stupid idea it is not a
stupid idea every second he's using this
world then I said oh I don't you are a
good boy isn't it
you are very good boy isn't it he said
yes I said the good work doesn't use
this world so can you throw the stick
please
so he thrown this day so in the night I
had a dinner so then I asked her Weston
how I was taking him on the walk and he
was lifting constantly lifting the world
is to be a stupid stupid so how we did
learn this world
so he said q one day we had having
dinner at the table and he got hurt so
he banged the table I said he was stupid
he hurt my son
it's a c4 you see how the seed planted
because at that time the children minds
are not so you know their focus they're
less then because you have so many duty
response to do that they're very focused
so they're like what was a blank sheet
of paper so we write so therefore so
where it has to go the parent has to be
our subconscious what word hype to you
is yeah isn't it yes so this
everything's so careful you've seen for
example here like in America I've seen
many like suppose if the boy
suppose they spill water or the bit of
glass what did you say Oh timeout you'd
put them inside the room and lock it
so it's wrong so what is happening it's
creating fear because the boy saw of my
mom it's okay let's clean it up together
yeah so the partner said then he saw say
he's terrified say not comprehend yeah
but the moment say who paint on the back
he say of my voice really care for you
don't do that you see so this affection
but when when he were common good yeah
isn't it yeah but when your mind is all
it is there and we do then you react the
parts of the panic button all the time
and that's why the productivity going
down if he senses down and their sake I
don't have time so all you know the
deadline is not met then you get a
stress out you can't sleep you get
exactly than feared losing job and all
kind of things how is the ripple effects
so there if I said mind is one thing is
rippling all the time it's always just a
monkey mind so there is a time where it
leads we're out of so I call it now in
neuro science it's called
neuroplasticity so that's how he's so
powerful so meditation as we said
rightly and I say all the time give
spiritual practice the spiritual life
leading a spiritual life and for it's a
little bit more simple like you said
it's it's the way that you treat
something like the spilling of the water
that's how you plant the seed in the
kid's mind for the future because it's
tough to get the kid to be likes close
your eyes and breathe for example you
know he had like a sec he don't throw
the you put you things you had in tres
you know in the garbage so we learn in
it so forth
so what is this is how it there from the
very beginning their Lord mm-hmm isn't
it
I mean let me take you to another point
that I really think that you should talk
about it is how do we take the
incompleteness of corporations and turn
that into completeness for example
plastics lots and lots of plastics on
the planet but we already know how to
make these biodegradable materials ones
that can go right back into the soil
systems no problem so it costs more to
make the biodegradable ones than the
plastic ones and people again
shareholder value all that stuff how do
we get corporations closer to
completeness again you said yes
meditation all its good stuff but what
is the ethics how do we get epochs into
the boards so that what I do find today
like you know like in a corporate sector
there the rule is there you they're
becoming more philanthropic s-- because
certain percentage has to go and because
the millennial generation and the
jennszoo younger kids they look at
companies and they say the ones that
impact the world better yeah more values
yeah more sustainability we buy their
products yeah
no the rather saying so this cooperate
called the human responsibility that
what I'm saying at the beginning you
talked about it you said all the
corporate who are the corporate people
the human beings I Anu isn't it like
sacct example anyone you know like you
take it like on that the Angela Elliot
was telling the over hello they are not
very highly they give three door or
something lower his income that they're
making more much sometimes it's not
always exactly right no no but I think
you because the second death
that what you are talking about you know
so that the same thing so when you have
feel like you know I have to say you
know I'm making money but I also had to
contribute also like now example in San
Francisco and everywhere and the rule
has been set okay like here there that
building all the higher edges of
apartment so there's certain SEC you
know you have to fix all the what he
calls affordable act means you know
Widow market rate so they have to live
certain things so but is that what that
philosophy that something like you know
you can drag a horse to the pond but you
can't force him to do it
so the mental psychology has to the
individual psychology has to be change
and as I said could change that
psychology there's no other means
there's no other tools there's no other
method north of the technique by which
it individual can develop kind of you
know management science so that has to
be blended together has to be so that is
the bottom line
that is a large yeah and then I wrote
some all the problem because it all the
you the individual that what makes one
individual can make things better for
the whole world other people can
accurate he book yeah you know the same
one human being but so that's how the
society is so now there are certain rule
the people at the time pass but they're
changing so now they're corporate people
that take a responsibility like they
have a philanthropic must've yes and
here the people they said the people are
I said I I always believe and it's true
because in our DNA to be kind to be
loving to be careful to be compassionate
but when we are colored with supper the
person is in a depressed or suppose is
angry then he cannot he doesn't care
anybody right he just he banked someone
he just do something you know he the
instinct yeah instinctively he just
everything is his coloring he becomes
blind like you see that what is
happening in the student life and
then crime is happening it's a proper
moment it's just people because then you
feel good when suppose I say Oh Ellen I
have seen him various smiling but when I
walk on the market and CEO a short
temper is ailing this other side of our
son yeah so it's all the things you know
it's all about individual I said
individual play very very vital because
our society society is made by the human
hand and psychology the societies guide
about collective psychologists
so if our psychology individual
psychology a collective sigh Elizabeth
suppose you create a friend all the
friends we have good time we have a nice
time and we laugh and you become good so
the killer does in the Faustian how do
you think that once we get better at
finding completeness spiritual science
in our management what will it look like
to progress as the world away from the
nationalism the tribalism more more
towards of collectivism more towards
that love and that harmony what does
that transition look like in the next
couple as I said very beginning the
stage we said Kelly we live in the
global world suppose do that ever
thought of it there'll be some person
from East will be this different they
look differently speak differently
suppose you go to any company you see
there people from all over the world
take the beauty of San Francisco yeah
they're forming everywhere yeah
so this is the what accosted the world
is so beautiful because the to the
diversity is melting pots melting pot
the diversity you know no other word you
to life will become what you call say
not honest yeah
suppose this is a cave example we'll
keep record to Walden be at Parker
there's a real garden is a rose garden
you go to Botanical Garden God so many
car flowers are there is that so
diversity so the word is the beautiful
do to divert
so that's I as if you liked it or not
so that's how the technology help
suppose you find the people Messiah
appear from India from North Korea and
everywhere you know it's Chinese people
and all that so this is how it is so
it's questioning it all if you are able
to tolerate you happy if we become
intolerant they were unhappy so you
individually we are cause for sovereigns
yeah so there were see you are the cause
root cause for the problem and they were
the solver problem also we should have
intolerance for for murder
things like that right that is all the
growth there's a wise example the white
happened a matter fascist Junta why do
people commit such a heinous crime
because in the beginning they are not
taught like separate thing that was
rotten I was fine because there's
something that what I think there were
the people become very vengeful yeah for
example you know you treat mistreat
people then what do people they're not
flock together so what I talk like they
said to the very primary you believed at
the my whole existence it depends on so
many factors it's not only I have to
take and take and take and take I have
to give also like I said in the human
existence like in every existence has
two handles one is called exist steel
medals and one is called utility others
over the existing existence existence
and utility and utility for example a
tree so that pre-exists
what it gives us it gives her serious
said he gave us fruits so as long as
oxygen oxygen exactly and we give carbon
dioxide they give and take so existing
it has values isn't it when they die you
make a furniture so it doesn't mean that
you have to do deforestation if you do
that you will disturb the ecosystem are
never
so then the flood comes the air
pollution comes and organizing so see
how so it's a very balancing thing it's
all about individual awareness yeah it's
all about personal one's individual
growth yeah how so his and that growth
is more than a small thing I didn't know
he did a small line you drive bigger
line who cares those things yeah
like suppose you know the ocean that
hundred and thousand legs by legs water
goes and become one with it
everyone thinks that they're working on
individual awareness everybody think now
it's coming this time coming I secure
why they spiritually as I said get
twenty million American they are
practicing and all every walk of life
that's amazing yeah if we want everyone
thinks that their spirit that they're
spiritually becoming more aware everyone
everything but I'm talking about maybe
more of the people that are that haven't
yet tried meditation or they haven't yet
they think it's too dogmatic no they
they think it's how could there be a
golden key you can't tell me how to live
my life so yeah how you made the
recommendation earlier just a couple
minutes yeah this is the one thing like
in my duties to suppose I go and talk so
I'm doing it you have practice you saw
that we went to the be Posner so you so
what you live we live in society yeah
isn't it yeah that's why the second word
by word motto
yeah so that where the awareness has
come like the result was that yeah yeah
I did I so knew how they map my brain Oh
eg deferred yeah wow the map - what's
that Sonya I don't think we did you show
me I can't I don't think so
we should devil its give it let's get a
zoom on it definitely it was while you
were meditating no I didn't retire that
is a somewhat broken hey they can't
so whatever that was the party of Angela
in oh yeah yeah will show you guys
sure yeah just one second please
very important points about meditation
just a couple minutes yeah 10 to 15
minutes yeah yeah exactly
thank you to blank thank you to blank
for being patrons may as well yeah yeah
shout out to well the stereo market at
6th Street in San Francisco for all of
the great AV equipment big shout out to
rapper Griffis one of our leading
patrons shoutout to the clear one family
office the Mike harden family office for
being patrons thank you thank you
shout out to Suresh and Ron and Anthony
and our simulation simulation team
getting a little shot of our director
and producer over there Ron Vargas get a
nice little shot of Ron oh yeah yeah
hopefully they saw our delicious array
of fruits and snacks and teas in the
back so if you come into the studio you
can also get a delicious array of food
fruits and snacks and teas do you
remember if it was in the photos or me
yeah Ron what's our timing looking like
as well how many more minutes
speak English for me okay so is tennis
after this we'll go into some simulation
questions on and we'll wrap it up
also shoes shoes off yeah yeah yeah
what's wrong with you
once you see the shoes pile over there
that it's a shoes off shoes off studio
yeah we got we got mayor mayoral
candidate Angela Alioto coming up at
3:00 p.m. so we'll be recording and
uploading that timing yeah we are going
to show these as live streams but so
Angela Elliot is coming up later that'll
be a blast will talk about San Francisco
mayoral race and what's important in the
city to accomplish Swamy and I actually
met at her event it was very cool we had
an amazing conversation earlier today
with a mano Ella and Andrew from connect
was really fun talking to them about
human connectivity actually it's a good
one it's a good one for Swami it's a
really good one for Swami Swami needs to
be connected to them as well
we're working on it we're working on it
you guys want to dance with me a little
bit and that's it so simulation is
taking a couple days to work on some of
our guests our patrons our equipment our
experience we're learning a lot from
other smart people I'll be taking a
couple days to crew Tony Robbins event
in San Jose to keep learning and growing
Ron is has a lot on his plate he's
acting actually you know in a movie it's
really exciting we got a couple of
post-production things to do for world's
fair and you know get the simulation
studio continuing to be beautiful thanks
to you at home actually that would be a
very powerful simulation actually if we
could get them to do a live event with
us 3,000 seat theater as you guys may
may know may not simulation has a very
big live event component we like to do
thousand two thousand plus seat theaters
with very high caliber guests we like to
try and inspire people to build the
future and so we ask our guests really
thought provoking questions about
challenging issues that humanity faces
we ask them lots of questions about
things like self-actualization how
people can find meaning and purpose in
life and so Tony would be a great guest
to help out with that and thanks to
people like you at home we have a studio
space where we can bring on people into
a safe and comfortable and friendly
environment where they have access to
all the tea and fruit and snacks they
want you know we get all this great
equipment thanks to you at home
we get provide you with great content
hopefully you enjoy it and then you can
pass it along with other people and it's
been so much just happen to you okay
well welcome put the lures of share link
we can put that in the bio later so I'm
a couple couple last questions
okay okay do you think we're alone in
the cosmos and not at all the drugs that
we are inseparable an insect
inseparable oh inseparable for the car
but do you think that other intelligent
life has formed in the cosmos it is
natural growth you know like some
example in the same class on top whether
Jesus ever normally marked on the pass
but the professor and the course is the
same sitter about once a trust under
efforts you know like I talked to you
know Oxford because I put all my heart
you know yesterday six eight hours
another my friends wish to go and have
it in a pub you know they have to be so
that's not about you know exactly the
efforts yeah yeah it's not that
something like God here to know it we
are all everyone has the same potential
but other people that opportunity other
don't interesting so it boils down to
the psychology of the individual minds
and then of the group together and then
it that depends on how sophisticated
this civilization can become absolutely
it I want to call it you know
intertwined yeah so what does it gives
society and individual after society is
made of individual you know like a house
house is not built by 1 bricks were
several bricks yeah so the same thing
yes that's good do you think that we are
in a computer simulation the time change
because this is a company I said get
taken Lodi is one expected there are so
many things you know like you said
technology times transportations the
road you know so they're different so
it's not only one field there's a
multiplex and complex you know yes
things so like the human body is the how
it's so complex so complex but they all
work in synchronicity is they do just
like the traffic systems in the economy
so this has to be you know in central
cities you know otherwise everything
will be in there then go to the MS do
you think that it's the it's possible
for an advanced civilization to have
harness the power of their star nuclear
five good example of inner as I said the
beginning you know how the technology
has chain we are we all having the
profit these two they have iPhones you
know experiment of how this how the
human time change you know like the
goalie at times are different instant
time was different you know yeah
so this out of time you know the social
changes so regeneration of the different
things to contribute a lot faster than
biology for you absolutely
take them to them when everybody so
complex like to the children's are more
smarter than us yeah when I was tending
Lanier was knowing anything about the
computer because they're from the birth
you know so it was experienced the life
changes you know because due to the how
they live how they brought of
environment you know so and there's a
generational wisdom always and I love
looking at 13 year olds and talking to
them about what they care about
yeah why do you care about this yeah and
then they teach me and I'll absorb from
the Rodin saying so you see how they are
because they had in different world you
know in same thing with a sixty eighty
or Rosa so why is what happened 50 years
ago teach me about what life was like
that one second this is our individual
learning have a curiosity to know yes so
the first step to know is to develop
curiosity yes
so curiosity is here is as important as
meditation they're very close in
importance America isn't necessary
curiosity of course the meditation is I
say put it this way
suppose there you say okay what are the
two chemical components of water we say
whether to one is called hydro
the oxygen so then say what assume the
ratio yeah so if you want then you have
to go to laboratory and make those
component with the ratio then you see
the water isn't it so it spiritually the
critical tools to apply those
theoretical thing in the practice and
then it becomes yeah yeah so that's what
I said and this is another little seed
that can be planted from Clarence's
curiosity one yeah so okay
last question what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful in the world is diverse
cities diversity yeah there was in the
nature diversity in planet diversity in
our human existence so that and that's
why I call what is it beautiful
Swami another thank you so thank you for
such a pleasure I know thank you
you have wanted to so much a list that
you're bringing our world one of us does
it so that's how you know everyone is a
make a contribution but it's all we are
together into it and that what I feel
you know I can do our part yeah
we're counting on you absolutely what
was there that's why we're counting on
all the all together this should come
you know everyone is there ascetic
everything has two important against
your fellows when they exist they have
it's valued yeah when they die they have
utility so the same thing we exist you
press the air so you can life is so
precious we can contribute but we can do
it when we are happy yes suppose we have
personally unhappy every bring
unhappiness to everybody if person they
get a will for every word is negative
you know yeah and that's a they do all
the take you source them so clean your
own room of course um inner management
first yes virtual science then goes into
the world yeah and then we could doesn't
want to cleaning up clean up clean up so
that's the Wester to you know yeah
all right we're art we're all tasked to
do a little bit of cleaning yeah yes yes
bring our positive beautiful definitely
second incorporate integrate you know
the signs of a spiritual accommodation
in our life so that life will be coming
up yes because you live in to the
different world all right
follow him we'll put his links in the
bio please do check out his other
content and also the universal yoga
center yeah definitely check that out
help so many people as well in the world
via that huge yes I have talked about on
must a million people saw and didn't
talk almost a million people awesome
alright thank you so much everyone
that's amazing continue crushing it
thanks the team thank you guys for
tuning in talk more soon